I don't think that's how it works mate
Dylan if that is the most attractive you
will ever look then I don't even want to
imagine what you'll look like when
you're at your ugliest you may not be
masculine but you also aren't feminine
instead you are you are weird and
artificial you are manufactured and
lifeless you are unearthly and Eerie you
are like some kind of human deep fake
that's what you are the identity that
you're fleeing the best you can hope for
is some kind of limbo the worst of all
worlds and yet even in that limbo state
you will still be a man just not one
that any of us can respect or take
seriously
use notes as well yeah he made some
notes
I mean
do you reckon he's into her
it so it does look like the sort of
thing somebody would say that when
they're slightly obsessed with somebody
yeah exactly look factually he's not
wrong yeah is he
no
factually yeah I I don't look if your
job is to win hearts and Minds
I don't think this is the best way of
doing it what if it's your job to get
clicks online again but do clicks lead
to changing of opinion no I I don't
think he's trying to change anyone's
opinion what do you think he's trying to
do then
uh
he's trying to make people on his side
feel like he's done something cool and
said something that they think I think
do you think that yeah yeah well he's
not trying to change Dylan
who's going to listen to that and go you
know what maybe I'm not trans yeah yeah
I don't think any of that is intended as
an address to Dylan Mulvaney Etc it's a
it's an address to his audience yeah
isn't it yeah
yeah because if you were trying to
change someone's mind you probably
wouldn't talk like that yeah
yeah I completely agree I completely
agree I just I just look at that and
just go
even people on his own side were like
hold on a bit mate
chat loved it they don't agree with us
they all loved it yeah what do they
saying they're saying that we're mind
reading
and he's trying to tell the truth uh
well as you know we believe in telling
the truth as well yeah we've interviewed
Matt but that was mean and and nasty and
mean-spirited
um
am I sometimes mean a nasty mean
spirited yeah but I'm not proud of it
and
I don't think that's the way that you
advance anything personally
yeah I I think the problem is is that
all that type of rhetoric does is just
dive a deeper wedge between opposing
fractions
and actually if you have the same
message but you make your tone more
conciliatory
and
more accessible then you would stand a
better chance of your message succeeding
than by using that type of light but
again it depends on your definition of
success if you're if your definition of
success is to make people feel good
about agreeing with you is to advance
your narrative with the people that
already think like you is to get
attention is to dunk on somebody who
your side and your team dislikes then I
I I'd say is very successful I mean like
I say people in the chat are very like
they're totally on board they're like
yeah but Dillon Mulvaney is you know uh
disrespecting women all the time don't
disagree with you you know that
um but
you know it's one of those things that
there's a constant debate it's like do
you fight fire with fire or do you try
and reach out to people and I think I
personally increasingly I'm trying to
reach across that divide rather than
pandering simply to the people that
already agree with me
um it doesn't mean other people should
but I certainly feel that way yeah I I
don't think ultimately
I I genuinely believe that most people
feel this we want a society that is more
harmonious we want a society where the
rancor the resentment the anger
is toned down and we can live in a
society that is more civil where each
side is prepared to actually
say what they think and listen that's
ultimately I think what everyone wants
or not what everyone wants the vast
majority of people want
I don't see how that can be achieved
through this type of rhetoric someone
says not sticking up for women is not
civil well I think of any YouTube
channel that you could name I mean I
haven't watched every YouTube channel on
YouTube obviously
go my research make some a professional
we've done a fair bit in terms of
talking about
trans and its impact on women and girls
and young people in particular so I
don't think either Francis or I could be
accused of not standing up for women or
for the truth by the way
um so it's not about that I think it's
it's much more about how do you do it
and when it comes to the trans issue I I
actually you know put Kelly J King Posey
Parker she changed how I think about it
because I think Clarity and precision is
extremely important
but you know I how many people
like those of you who agree with Matt
are obviously going to agree with it
right but how many people who are on the
fence are going to be con converted by
that intervention I mean it was very
likable while she was delivering it mate
I was there going the man's charm is off
the scale
you know there is a way to do these
things where you can be clear and
precise I mean even I would say even
Posey Parker is much more diplomatic and
yeah you know uh civil about the way
that she communicates about these things
um and look Matt's you know Matt's
allowed to say whatever he wants to say
but from my perspective I don't think
that's the way you advance the
conversation to me that's why Helen
Joyce is so much more effective on this
particular subject than that is because
Helen delivers what she has to say she
doesn't hold back
she has her message she says it
but she doesn't use rhetoric and words
that are inflammatory and are designed
to antagonize yeah she just goes here's
what here are the facts this is what I
think this is why I think it here you
are and uh Ali Ali shakulta says it's
not about converting anymore it's about
stopping this nonsense okay fine how is
how is that video contributing to
stopping this nonsense
how I'm I'm open to be persuaded
genuinely explain to me the mechanism by
which doing that video stops the
nonsense
and and also so if you by nonsense you
mean uh trans people in women's sports
uh by nonsense I imagine you mean the
transitioning of children by nonsense
you mean
um we're talking about male rapists and
female prisoners male rapists and female
prisons you
how is that video stopping any of that
I I don't follow the how how is it
stopping the nonsense it doesn't make
any sense to me but again I'm open to be
persuaded how is having a go at an
individual person who I don't like and
whose Behavior I don't like how is that
stopping the nonsense that I that's the
part of it that I don't really follow
because I'll be honest with you if I
thought that that video was going to
stop the nonsense if I thought that
video was going to stop one percent of
the nonsense I would I wouldn't give a
that it's mean and nasty because I
agree with you stopping the nonsense is
important but I don't think that's what
stops the nonsense at all what I think
it does is it makes people feel good
about someone they hate being dunked on
and having their opinion regurgitated
back for them in a way that makes them
slightly uh happier that somebody's
articulated that's it I don't think it's
advancing anything and look think about
the rhetoric that people or say uh that
people use against turfs for it and I'm
using that word because that's a word
that side of the argument uses their
mean they're nasty they're cool they're
hateful they're unfeeling
right well that will convince them
otherwise mate yeah exactly they'll look
at that and go you know what that's the
man who cares I actually think there's a
much bigger risk that things like that
perpetuate the nonsense because it's the
easiest thing now for anyone who is uh
Pro all of this nonsense to go well this
is the face of the opposition to what
we're doing yeah right when there are
plenty of as we discussed far more
reasonable people who are opposed to it
who are actually being taken seriously
who are actually going into major
institutions and pushing back against
this stuff in a way that a scene is
constructive
whereas if all people think about when
they think about the pushback against
the excesses of trans ideology is
something like that a lot of people are
going to be turned off from even
engaging with it yeah right and this is
the reason why so many of our interviews
about the trans issue I think do
persuade people is they're not presented
in that way like our first interview
with Posey she doesn't say anything
hateful she's just very very clear she's
very direct she's not mean or nasty or
mean-spirited you can see that she's
coming from a place of compassion and I
understand people go well she's just
calling out he's she's just calling out
their Ridiculousness at all I don't
think so actually I think we all know
what their thickness of it is it seems
to me much more like he's just having a
go at someone because it's going to get
attention and look there's another way
that you tackle this which is there's a
very very very
easy argument to make when you tackle
this you go look it's not about trans
people it's about ideology I'm
criticizing the ideology I'm criticizing
the system the Paradigm the the way that
they view the world it's inherently
flawed here are the reasons why if we
carry on implementing this ideology into
schools into the public systems into
institutions this is going to be the end
game and innocent people are going to
get hurt this is why I disagree and you
remove the individual that's how you win
the argument you don't win the argument
by targeting one person however much you
may dislike that person or or not
approve of their actions you're never
going to win that you're never going to
win the argument it's a very good point
man that's a very good point because the
moment you start attacking individual
people whether whether rightly or
wrongly by the way people will dismiss
what you say because because of the
personal nature of it and of course like
I say I don't think Matt is wrong on on
the facts of what he's saying I mean
it's it's not untrue but it was is that
the most effective way to to fight for
whatever he's fighting I don't think so
it's a very effective way to get people
to follow him on social media to
subscribe to the Daily why I imagine Etc
but I don't think it's constructive no
personally and look there are plenty of
you that seem to disagree tell us why so
stop giving an inch to the Dylan so the
illibrations don't take him well Bryson
I'm the Bryson I don't think that's how
it works mate I think we can I think
it's possible to prevent male rapists
from going into women's prison without
being nasty to individual trans people
who are not rapists yeah I think that
that should be possible like that is an
aspiration of mine that I believe is
achievable you know what I mean I don't
know why I'm doing this accent it's from
Sweden she's from Sweden
KKK it's scapegoating the backlash is
here and Truth is stuck in the middle
thank you Bob for standing your gun to
keep saying well this is the this is the
I've said this from day one the biggest
threat of the woke left is they're gonna
cause a backlash that's gonna make
that's going to be the exact equal and
opposite reaction and and I think it's
on the way yeah to be honest with you if
you look at the way that people's brains
have been broken uh by the by the fact
that they so distrust the mainstream
media they believe anything the old
media tells them now that's an example
of it the anti-woke are starting to do
my head and frankly and I've talked
about this before and so have you and I
think this is this is the problem right
we I don't know about you guys I don't
want to be going off the deep end in
either Direction no right and once you
find yourself attacking people as
individuals with no humor no play uh
just for the sake of getting what I
think in my opinion is getting attention
I don't think you're doing a good thing
this is exactly what the work left you
all the time calling people names saying
they're racist all of this stuff when
it's not true yeah you know and this is
why you call him someone a groomer how's
this person a groomer who have they
groomed
and that's another problem it's just
like you said you know it's the world
it's like the woke left do with just
with smears you if you're gonna call
someone a groomer
you best be sure that they've actually
groomed someone yeah that is a very
serious thing to level and I look I
don't know I don't know but I'm just
saying the the phrase okay groomer which
has now become widespread amongst a
certain minority of people on the right
that's just like that's that's basically
and there are some groomers yeah I'm
just not sure that this specific person
is one yeah right but using that as a
sort of catch-all for people who
disagree with you is just as dangerous
as calling people
who for instance say that in Mass
immigration causes disruption in society
a racist or a white supremacist uh and
people are saying as in grooming their
minds to a way of thinking well in that
case we're groomers as well yeah right
aren't we I mean people could say that
we are grooming young minds to believe
something that they disagree with right
the offensive comedy should be allowed
for yeah I mean that's not what a
groomer is a groomer is someone who
tries to change how people behave in
order to like abuse them and have sex
with them or whatever I don't think
that's what this person's doing yeah
right so words have meanings hmm
fair game I think they are but it
doesn't mean that you can just say
whatever nasty you want about them
like no you can you should be allowed to
say whatever you want in my opinion
doesn't mean I would then approve of
what you said no and that's I think the
issue here yeah
uh thank you spend it appreciate it
Ricardo again Junior
I am conflicted did Walsh go too far but
I know trans people personally who would
agree with him because of how did Dylan
turned this into theater yeah so do I
yeah yeah they would and I agree with
the facts of what he said it's the it's
the method of the delivery that I'm not
I'm less uh on board with thank you
Ricardo uh Dawn with the two chord says
well I thought he was fit
thanks Don appreciate it
oh I I think this is one of your boys
any thoughts about the left governments
on Latin America one who are raised
individual borders Constitution and
story to make a single country AKA
Soviet Latin American Union